donne-t-il sa confiance au nouveau
gouvernement à l'heure de la rigueur
après deux premiers gestes symboliques
françois chérèque le secrétaire général
de la cfdt l'invité preuve par 3 bonsoir
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous alors que
tous nous accable le chômage qui
augmente la croissance qui chute et le
pouvoir d'achat qui recule désespérant m
désespérant n'est ce pas françois
chérèque même si le premier ministre
lors de son discours de politique
générale nous appellent à retrouver
confiance dans notre destin comment la
cfdt veut se faire entendre dans ce
contexte bien vous allez nous le dira
avec moi dans un instant bruno
francheski de l' agence france-presse
puis perrine tarneaud de public sénat et
puis les téléspectateurs peuvent
intervenir dans cette émission vous
poser leurs questions par le biais de
l'application tivi tchèque de notre
partenaire orange jean marc ayrault a
donc fixé la ligne politique sous les
contraintes budgétaires pour vous la
rigueur est bien là malgré les
dénégations du premier ministre c'est la
rigueur
écoutez j'ai pas l'habitude de de
changer de d'expression en fonction du
gouvernement
c'était la rigueur avant l'arrivée de
françois hollande c'est la rigueur après
vous l'avez dit vous-même pour la
première année depuis 1984 le pouvoir
d'achat des français va baisser dans les
ménages
les salaires des fonctionnaires sow est
bloqué la valeur du point depuis deux
ans ça va être la troisième année ce
sont des mesures de rigueur moi j'ai pas
peur des mots le problème aujourd'hui
c'est pas de savoir s'il faut faire des
économies c'est de dire comment on
arrive à faire baisser cette fameuse
dette de l'état mais surtout comment le
fait avec des mesures justes se dire que
ce ne soit pas comme c'était le cas
avant en particulier les salariés sur le
pouvoir d'achat qui les payent accord la
justice la justice le mot été maintes
fois repris par le premier ministre dans
son discours de politique générale est
ce que vous faites donc une différence
entre la rigueur d'avant la rigueur
d'aujourd'hui la rigueur de droite la
rigueur de gauche
je vous le dirai après on a déjà nos m
on a déjà de quoi juger de quoi juger de
quelle façon pour le mans n'a encore pas
les principales mesures ce que je
remarque c'est qu'on nous a promis
qu'ils auraient plus de baisses de
fonctionnaires globalement c'est le cas
maintenant la vraie question c'est de
savoir est-ce qu'on va continuer à être
dans une baisse mathématique
s'enquit du sens où est ce qu'on va
débattre de l'emploi public là où on a
besoin et de la façon dont on fait les
choses et ce à partir de ce moment là
que je juge pour la stabilisation
effectivement de des effectifs globaux
de la fonction publique et à être un bon
point et là c'est une rupture positive
avec la rigueur de droite
c'était une promesse de la campagne j'ai
pas me plaindre quand des politiques
respectent leurs promesses
la cfdt a toujours dit la priorité on va
parler de la compétitivité de notre pays
un des éléments du manque de
compétitivité
c'est le niveau de qualification c'est
les retards que dans notre pays on a 150
mille jeunes qui sortent du système
scolaire tous les ans sans qualification
c'est un problème donc on met l'accent
sur ce sujet là well inévitablement
c'est une bonne chose alors on reste
encore un peu sur les fonctionnaires
françois chérèque parce que vous avez vu
ce qu'a dit la cour des comptes à
effectif constant dont vous vous
félicitez de la stabilité des effectifs
de la fonction publique et bien il n'y a
plus aucune marge de manoeuvre
donc eh bien il y aura toujours le gel
du point d'indicé aucune augmentation
salariale afin dé la cour de comptes et
les à effectif constant et à recettes
constantes
donc on va voir le gouvernement si le
gouvernement essaye de trouver d'autres
recettes
donc je pense que le débat aujourd'hui
je m'adresse pas la cour des comptes
la cour des comptes fait son travail
elle donne des directions maintenant
c'est au gouvernement
si le gouvernement pense qu'il va
pouvoir durer cinq ans en évitant je
dirais une évolution une refonte des
grilles salariales a fonctionné c'est
pas possible pour une raison simple
l'augmentation du smic et là des actions
pas seulement dans les branches
professionnelles du privé ont souffert
lui parce que inévitable ans le salaire
minimum dont fonctionnaires en dessous
du smic
donc vous êtes obligés de revoir les
choses impossibles la lettre ouverte à
un recul par rapport à nicolas sarkozy
puisque lui il avait essayé de redonner
aux fonctionnaires vous le savez la
moitié des 800 millions d'économies
réalisées par le non remplacement d'un
fonctionnaire sur deux partant à la
retraite là aujourd'hui il n'aurait pu
aller aller voir les fonctionnaires pour
leur demander où ils se passer ce sera
distribution donc là je pense que c'est
plutôt un élément de communication donc
ce que ce que je le message que je fais
passer on fera passer dans la conférence
sociale sur cette table ronde
de dire aujourd'hui on a deux soucis on
a le souci d'évolution de carrière je
vais en parler mais il ya aussi le souci
de l'organisation du travail stern la
déstructuration de l'organisation des
services publics d des commandes y reste
des administrations de l'état ne peut
pas durer
complet continuellement donc il faut
revoir cette organisation du travail
pour rendre un bon service à la
population
je prends des exemples tout le temps je
prends souvent l'exemple des sous
préfectures dans les viandes un
département de montagne
il ya des sous préfectures sous
préfectures à leur rendre service aux
petites entreprises en particulier
qu'ont besoin d aide et d information
sur l'état si vous supprimez la
sous-préfecture qui existe vous avez un
service aux petites entreprises que vous
rendez pu alors que le discours du
redressement productif c'est aussi
d'aider les petites entreprises
donc quelle est la logique là dedans et
c'est de ça dont on veut parler lâche le
changement de méthode si ça d'accord
mais tout en tous les cas on nous
annonce -2 5% des effectifs dans les
ministères non prioritaires donc hors
éducation nationale sécurité justice est
ce que ça ça vous paraît jouable
moi ça me semble difficile à beaucoup
d'endroits c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'ai dit là non ce qui est une annonce
uniquement mathématiques elle ne peut
pas fonctionner je dirais le la sentence
qui vient d'en haut et qui tombe dans
les administrations au supprime deux
fonctionnaires sur trois qui partent à
la retraite
ça peut pas marcher par contre à
certains endroits il va falloir
renforcer où ils ont des besoins et je
prends un exemple je n'en reviens pas là
dessus
à d'autres endroits peut-être il ya du
mou et c'est dans la discussion qu'on va
pouvoir trouver des solutions et ce que
j'attends moi du gouvernement
aujourd'hui c'est de changer de méthode
et la réaction qui était assez vifs sur
ce sujet là c'était d'abord un problème
de méthode d'accord donc vous voulez une
gestion harmonieuse en quelque sorte et
pas la serpe des effectifs de la
fonction publique pour résumer qu'est ce
qu'on a observé dans la sélection
on s'est dit mais pour comment se
fait-il que dans les zones semi-rurales
semi urbaines à 70 km des centres villes
les gens ont voté front national parce
qu'ils ont le sentiment d'abandon ils
ont le sentiment qu'on s'occupe plus
d'eux ils ont pu une de police de
proximité
ils ont plus un service public qui
répond la préfecture le la perception et
autres si on veut répondre à cette
sentiment d'abandon il va bien falloir
changer la méthode d'accord voilà
message transmis
vous avez parlé du coup de pouce jamais
dire le mini coup de pouce pour le smic
un françois chérèque est ce que ce n'est
pas finalement un coup de bluff avec la
hausse de la csg que demande la cour des
comptes avec la hausse des cotisations
retraites pour financer le retour
partiel à 60 ans et puis la fin des
exonérations sur les heures
supplémentaires et ce n'est pas un coup
de bluff ou thé final le positionnement
la position de la cfdt sur le smic c'est
que de dire une chose simple c'est que
les marges de manoeuvre sur le smic là
aussi été réduites pour une raison
simple on le sait ces petites
entreprises et que ces petites
entreprises ont des marges de maryse
réduite mais ceci dit moi je crie plus
exigeant que les syndicats qui disent il
faut un smic à 1700 80 euros sachant
très bien qu'ils n'auront pas donc déjà
ils font je dirais de faux espoirs
vis-à-vis de ses rêves qu'elle exige
mais je vais vous expliquer la mine et
non mais oui nous aurions tenté mais lui
dont on peut pas rester là parce que le
problème aujourd'hui en france ces
quatre autres salariés au smic
il ya trop de salariés qui restent toute
leur carrière au smic et pourquoi il ya
trop de salariés au smic
tout simplement on dépense tous les ans
par le budget de l'état 25 milliards
d'euros pour aider les bas salaires dans
les entreprises
résultat moins vous payez un salarié
plus vous êtes aidez nous nous allons
proposer et la l'exigence et va être
fort de la cfdt c'est qu'on aide en
particulier dans les branches
professionnelles ou on fait des
déroulements de carrière pour que le
smic soit un salaire d'embauché le smic
peut pas être un salaire ou un genre est
maintenant maladroit mais ça c'est plus
exigeant c'est plus difficile mais c'est
annie entier mais là il ya la décision
immédiate et vous m'avez pas répondu et
je vous dirai ce que j'ai je répondis le
on annonce la hausse des cotisations
retraite
la fin des exonérations sur les heures
supplémentaires peut-être demain une
hausse de gs que donc tout cela n'est
pas un coup porté aux classes moyennes
c'est ce que dit non la droite alors dit
jean marc ayrault dit qu'elles seront
préservés quel est votre avis à vous mon
avis à moi sur la foi d'exonération des
heures supplémentaires et sans les
casser
je parle d'eux les entreprises qui font
des heures supplémentaires réellement
ils ont besoin c'est de petites
entreprises les moins de 20 salariés
là les exonérations des heures
supplémentaires est d'accord avec moi et
c'est intéressant de dire à ces
entreprises là puisque vous avez encore
cette marge de manoeuve là vous pouvez
pas laisser vos salariés tout en
sourires et les aide doit être
conditionnée donc ayons un peu de sens
là dessus hélas souvent c'est pas les
classes moyennes la seleçao
modeste donc là on est les plus modestes
dans les autres entreprises ou en abuser
des heures supplémentaires ont détourné
la mesure pour augmenter les salaires
des salaires sans payer de charges
sociales
moi je trouve normal qu'on annule cette
exonération parce que c'était
défavorable à l'or donc là vous êtes
d'accord
est ce que vous diriez plus globalement
que il est normal que finalement notre
pouvoir d'achat en prennent un coup pour
réduire la dette et les déficits mais ça
dépend de qui on parle
ça dépend du qui ont pas un jour de
l'ensemble des français ils sont aujourd
hui mais trois milliards d'euros à
trouver tout le monde je refuse qu'on
regarde l'ensemble des français jeudi
les français ne sont pas tous dans la
même situation vis-à-vis du pouvoir
d'achat si vous habitez et vous êtes
obligé de de louer un appartement très
cher et que cet appartement on n'a pas
une maîtrise des loyers vous n'êtes pas
dans la même situation que si vous êtes
propriétaire faisait les moyens
d'acheter votre votre appartement si
vous avez des transports vous êtes en
province que vous n'avez pas votre carte
de transport comment mieux prin
parisienne et que vous payer l'essence
qui est très cher vous n'êtes pas dans
la même situation que l'exemple de la
hausse je vais au bout excusez moi mais
de bon raisonnement
parce qu'il est important parce que
derrière ce que je dis au gouvernement
c'est que vous pouvez pas simplement
avoir eu une vision macro il faut que
vous preniez aussi des mesures qui
aident les dépenses contraintes et les
gens dans leurs situations quotidiennes
c'est de ça dont ils ont besoin dans ma
situation quotidienne mon problème comme
enjeu le résout c'est pour ça que les
solutions sur difficile à construire
c'est pour ça que la méthode de dialogue
est très importante
et bien justement le dialogue qu'il va
avoir lieu dans quelques jours mais
est-ce que la hausse de la csg vous
paraîtrait acceptable nous nous semble
que la cgc la seule piste qui est
acceptable à condition qu'on supprime
l'augmentation de la tva qu'elle avait
été faite par le précédent gouvernement
le premier ministre kazakh d'ipad hausse
de la tva à condition qu'on pourquoi la
housse de la cgc le plus acceptable
parce que les revenus du capital les
revenus du patrimoine participe donc il
faut regarder que c'est hot cg puis 7 je
dirais neutre au niveau du pouvoir
d'achat dans les entreprises et à ce
moment là nous sommes prêts à débattre
puisqu'on va en parler du coût du
travail et du transfert d'une partie sur
la fiscalité
alors je vous écoute 1 depuis le début
de cette émission françois chérèque mon
sur le coup de pouce petit vous
l'acceptez vous le comprenez sur la
route de la cgt envisagez vous
l'acceptez également alors si je vous
demande est-ce que vous accordez votre
confiance
j'ai au discours du premier ministre
savait vraiment ce que vous allez me
coûter ce que j'ai dit
j'ai dit que j'acceptais le problème du
smic à conditions et c'est pour ça que
je suis bien amusé attendez là je la
balme ans non non non non je répondrai
quand j'aurai la réponse est là nous
avons vous avez écouté le discours du
premier ministre il n'a pas parlé des
sujets sociaux précisément parce que
nous avons une conférence sociale je
vais pas vous couper leur mais
exactement
c'est la raison pour laquelle les
réponses que j'ai sur le pouvoir d'achat
je voulais dix jours à ce moment là les
réponses que j'ai sur le financement de
la protection sociale ce genre à ce
moment là sur le le développement
d'économies aussi donc je dirais ravi
témoin après l'accord pourrait vous
répondre je retiens que vous estimez
quand même que nous sommes passés d'une
rigueur de droite à une rigueur de
gauche semblent plus claires c'est vous
qui faites cette interprétation la la
rigueur elle ne me paye pas parce que
c'est quelque chose de difficile pour la
population mais en même temps je sais
très bien et la cfdt le dis depuis très
longtemps nous ne pouvait pas continuer
à transmettre des dettes excessives à
nos enfants
ça c'est un élément essentiel c'est de
globalement quel est l'héritage derrière
donc je crois qu'aujourd'hui il y à une
partie de la population qui fait des
efforts par contre la rigueur est
acceptable si la population la partie de
la population qu'en difficulté on pense
à eux et on les aide très bien leur
rigueur acceptable mais pas à n'importe
quel prix et pas pour tous
france exactement c'est bien résumé le
single je me fais mieux résumé françois
chérèque alors vous l'avez dit l'emploi
mais aussi le pouvoir d'achat le
financement de la protection sociale la
formation autant de thèmes il nous reste
sept au total a précisé premier ministre
qui seront traités lors de la conférence
pour l'emploi la semaine prochaine
il ya une conférence qui ne sera pas une
conférence spectacle a dit jean marc
ayrault et il a dit également il n'y
aura aucun sujet tabou alors justement
avant d'accueillir bruno francheski de
l' agence france-presse voyons la
question de la productivité et donc du
coût du travail en france question
toujours controversé les experts
s'affrontent mais il semble bien que le
différentiel avec l'allemagne se soit
aggravée ces dernières années alors que
l'europe attend le sait des réformes des
marchés du travail en france tam tran
huy le travail coûte il trop cher en
france avec un coût horaire moyen de 34
euros et 20 centimes en 2011
la france compte parmi les pays
européens dont le coût du travail est le
plus élevé avec leurs 30 euros et 10
centimes les allemands font mieux mais
nous sommes à égalité si l'on rapporte
ce coût à la productivité
le problème c'est que la france perd du
terrain par rapport à l'allemagne
c'est vrai que depuis quelques années on
observe une augmentation importante du
coût du travail en france ça une
conséquence très importante c'est
qu'aujourd'hui le taux de marge des
entreprise est aujourd'hui beaucoup plus
faible en france que dans d'autres pays
européens de l'ordre de 28 % en france
contre par exemple 40 % en allemagne
or le taux de marché ce qui permet aux
entreprises d'investir de créer des
emplois augmenter pouvoir d'achat il
faut baisser le coût du travail sans
quoi la france ne sera plus compétitive
et n'attire à peu les investisseurs
les économistes tire la sonnette
d'alarmé à terra nova think tank proche
du ps comme au 6e rexecode qui porte la
voix des entreprises aujourd'hui au
terme de dix années de dérive du coût du
travail en france relativement à
l'allemagne et bien il y à une atrophie
de la base industrielle qui s'est
installée il ya une urgence à la
restauration de la compétitivité
même constat même solution il faut
immédiatement baisser le coût du travail
mais pas question de toucher aux
salaires les économistes propose
d'alléger les charges sociales qui
pèsent sur les entreprises est
d'effectuer un transfert vers l'impôt la
gauche est celle qui a inventé la csg
qui était une première étape du
transfert une partie du financement des
présents sociale vers l'impôt et donc la
gauche n'a pas à rougir d'examiner
aujourd'hui
la dégradation nous offrant une
connectivité un nouvelle étape de ce
transfert la csg est un très bon impôt
parce qu'il est à la fois juste et
équitable et qu'il offre beaucoup de
rendement la valeur ajoutée est une
autre piste que je pense qu'on devrait
également regardé avec attention alléger
le coût du travail pour doper la
compétitivité des entreprises s'étaient
déjà l'objectif de la tva sociale prévue
par nicolas sarkozy est écartée depuis
l'élection de françois hollande
autre piste de réflexion apporte
davantage de flexibilité au marché du
travail
mais sur ce sujet comme sur celui de la
tva le gouvernement marche sur des oeufs
voilà bruno franceschi de l' agence
france-presse
bonsoir donc productivité différentiel
de salaire entre l'allemagne et la haie
et la france mais en france dans la
pression que franchement les les plans
sociaux s'accumulent dernière en date
c'est psa s'est probablement sfr
bouygues et tout est ce que vous pensez
que la méthode montebourg et c'est du
gouvernement de façon générale et
appropriée écoutez là oui je ne veux pas
commencer à juger des gens qui sont là
depuis à moi mais ce qui est intéressant
de revenir sur le sur le le petit film
on parle de comment dire et de
comparaison du coût du travail moyenne
on est bien d'accord et on dit qu'avec
la compéti la la productivité des
salariés on est à égalité en france en
allemagne
sauf que la chose que vous ne t'ai pas
dit dans le dans la présentation
c'est que dans l'industrie coût du
travail plus élevé en allemagne c'est à
dire dans l'automobile vont parler le
plus jour le coût du travail est plus
élevé et qu'est ce qui fait qu'on est un
des qualités c'est que dans les services
et que dans certains secteurs le coup
ils travaillent bien moins élevé en
allemagne en particulier dans
l'agroalimentaire aujourd'hui on a des
emplois de l'agroalimentaire qui quitte
la france pour aller en allemagne parce
que là ya pas dessus de salaire minimum
et que le salaire moyen dans
l'agroalimentaire ses 5 euros donc on ne
peut pas continuer au niveau européen à
faire en sorte que la france l'allemagne
se fasse la compétition sous le coup du
travail des emplois de service alors
pourquoi il accepte les allemands pas
tout simplement comme ils ont un
problème de démographie que c'est les
immigrés qu'occupent ces emplois
c'est pas les travailleurs allemands
qu'occupe saison pour la les syndicats
forts dont on parle ils sont dans
l'industrie dans l'automobile hélas les
salaires sont élevés les enfants des
syndicalistes allemands ils sont dans
l'industrie
ils sont qualifiés par contre les
immigrés ils travaillent pour 5 euros
ils font concurrence avec les salariés
français donc là on voit bien qu'il ya
un problème européen et moi j'accepte
plus qu on présente la comparaison
compétitivité france en allemagne sans
dire la vérité
aujourd'hui il ya un problème de dumping
social alors qu'ils acceptent le dumping
avec la chine pas avec l'allemagne
donc ça c'est un élément je crois de
débat européen c'est pas simplement une
affaire d'opinion de dumping social
certes ça existe mais c'est aussi une
affaire de désindustrialisation jamais
les raisons et là on s'aperçoit qu'en
des faits peut-être un certain nombre de
deux grandes stratégies qui ont qui
n'ont pas été mises en place pour
précisément éviter par exemple la
déconfiture psa là vous avez raison de
deux problèmes psa d'une part des
mauvais choix
vous démontrez choix au niveau
industriel donc ça c'était c'est des
erreurs de stratégie industrielle et on
voit bien que et ça on le retrouve dans
d'autres secteurs professionnels
c'est le même cas de doute ou alors je
veux pas comparer le le poulet avec les
avec les voitures mais chedjou
ils ont choisi une belle gamme ou de
faire la transformation alimentaire ils
ont dit qu'on commençait avec des pays
étrangers là on a peu dans le même cas
chez peugeot on a choisi des petites
voitures
il y en a commencé par les voitures de
haut de gamme en particulier voitures
allemandes c'est pas un problème de coût
du travail
stratégie industrielle deuxièmement
anticipations c'est à dire quand il y en
a des difficultés en france on n'est pas
capable d'utiliser chômage partiel ce
que font les allemands d'une façon
massive mais aussi anticipation c'est à
dire qu'on voit un problème arrive et
nous sommes capables ils sont capables
en allemagne d'anticiper sur les
évolutions y compris au niveau social en
france on est capable de le faire
ce sac vous il ya quelques mois sur ce
plateau ici même vous les aviez anticipé
ces problèmes
un sociaux ses plans et vous aviez dit
qu'ils avaient été mis sous le tapis
pendant la cage avec les vous je n'en
avions pas une polémique oui polémique
est partie de parts de partout mais qui
qui vaut preuve je pouvais
inévitablement pas donné les preuves
parce que c'est difficile de m mais
derrière mais non mais mais armez vous
mais les preuves et les étés je vous ai
dis regarde et regretter vos émissions
le président de la république à l'époque
monsieur sarkozy convoquait monsieur
varin et lui disait je ne veux pas de
plan social
je ne veux pas que vous annonciez
licenciement résultats monsieur varin le
patron de de peugeot dans un pays
soi-disant où on est dans une
organisation libérale de marché
s'écraser en quelque sorte mais on a
perdu six mois je crains que les six
mois de perdus parce que nous sommes pas
capables d'anticiper ce soit des
chômeurs supplémentaires aujourd'hui
mais qu'est ce que peut faire l'état par
exemple pour pour essayer de d'éviter la
déconfiture 1 ps 1 qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire montebourg très content que je
pense qu'aujourd'hui montebourg d'abord
l'état va pas être responsable de la
situation sociale c'est évident mais
aujourd'hui le débat il ya deux débats
ya le débat sur la politique
industrielle ce qui est maintenant
appelée pompeusement le redressement
productif politique industrielle donc
vous allez parler compétitivité tout ça
ces éléments sur l'automobile sur
l'automobile puisque le gouvernement
réfléchit à un plan automobile on voit
bien qu'on peut plus refaire les
voitures les primes à la casse parce que
ça marche pas et qu'on est victime aussi
de ça parce que les gens à acheter des
voitures neuves des petites voitures
donc aujourd'hui on est en difficulté
aujourd'hui donc c'est plutôt une
réflexion sur je dirais l'avenir de
l'automobile en termes d'investissements
de recherche des nouveaux produits mais
qui rendront leurs effets dans deux dans
trois ans donc là on a un creux à passer
d'où le fait que socialement on est un
vrai débat sur l'avenir des salariés et
des sites a alors vous parlez de
réflexion je pensais je viens d'avoir
une assez importante la semaine
prochaine pour la conférence sociale à
laquelle évidemment vous participez
qu'est ce que vous en attendez
exactement est ce qu on a l'impression
que c'est d'en faire une sorte de grand
messe ont en quelque sorte dont il
sortira quoi peut-être d'autres pistes
mais rien de très concret façon en
france c'est comme ça les gars y a pas
de concertation on râle c'est la
concertation on dit qu'on ne veut pas
pourquoi vous devrez savoir ce qu'on
veut moi je suis plus forcée de vie qui
on peut avoir une concertation et
ambition serait qu'on justement mais
nous ce qu'on attend c'est d'abord un
diagnostic vous voyez bien que sur ces
sujets là il est quand même intéressant
de confronter gouvernement patronat et
ensuite qu'on ait des pistes de travail
et les pistes de travail il peut y avoir
de solution c'est à dire est ce qu'on
fait une négociation sur ce que la cfdt
appelle la sécurisation des parcours
professionnels c'est de l'accompagnement
des salariés tout leur long de leur
histoire professionnelle y compris quand
leur entreprise a des difficultés
d'autres diront une réforme du marché du
travail
donc est ce que on est capable de
regarder ce problème là puisqu'on voit
bien que c'est un souci en france est ce
qu'on est capable de donner un délai
pour négocier si on est d'accord sur cet
élément là on fera un bon
c'est rapide qui est attendu deuxième
élément on a des éléments je voulais dit
j'ai pris l'exemple tout à l'heure sur
cercle smic peut pas augmenter trop trop
fort mais est-ce qu'on va réorienter ses
fameux 25 milliards d'euros pour faire
en sorte qu'en les déroulements de
carrière protection sociale financement
de la protection sociale vient d'en
parler mais derrière retraite
nous on attend le gouvernement ou au
coin du bois sur les retraites
et là je suis très clair on avait fait
écrire dans la loi qu'il fallait
réfléchir à notre système de retraite
par répartition est ce qui va s'engager
dans l'année 2013 comme la loi l'y
incite à mettre à plat notre système de
retraites pour faire quelque chose de
plus vivant fin il s'est en même temps
que vos partenaires syndicaux sont pas
forcément d'accord sur votre ligne et
que ça risque d'être un peu compliqué
donc ils étaient deux choses où il veut
faire plaisir à des syndicats qui
veulent rien n'a bougé
moi ça fait dix ans que secrétaire
général je connais l'histoire
j'ai connu en 2003 il voulait pas bouger
mais maintenant il se félicite qu'on
fasse que ils ont critiqué en 2003 où il
leur fait confiance où il leur dit j'ai
peur d'eux j'ai peur d'eux dont change
rien mais là j'en reviens à ce que je
disais c'est nos enfants qui auront un
problème pour leurs systèmes de
retraites 85 % des moins de 35 ans n'ont
pas confiance dans le système de
retraite comment donne confiance aux
jeunes quand ils rentrent dans le marché
du travail mieux les accueillir mais
qu'ils aient confiance système social
c'est ça l'enjeu c'est pas de de
rassurer la cgt ou fo c'est de rassurer
les enfants c'est de rassurer les jeunes
c'est de rassurer ceux qui ont besoin de
systèmes de protection sociale
il a parlé de courage monsieur ayrault
ben là je vais voir fils en a sur celui
là ça va se concrétiser peut-être en
tout cas se manifester ce courage
pendant la conférence aujourd'hui un
tout petit peu là dessus parce qu'il ya
quand même sept gros sujet jean claude
mailly de vie d'yves on aurait pu se
contenter de 3 1
on aurait pu se contenter de trois c'est
à dire en fait l'emploi les salaires et
la fonction publique d'ailleurs vous y
êtes sensible mais également quoi ouais
mais est ce que l'on fait venir une
règle de mailly la seule chose qui
l'intéresse vous avez entendu emploi
salaires fonction publique j'ai proposé
qu'on parle de la pauvreté financement
de la protection sociale c'est aussi la
lutte contre la pauvreté
ça n'intéresse pas nos spots non non
mais ça n'intéresse pas celle j'ai
entendu ça n'intéresse pas le droit
le problème de la politique industrielle
il veut parler de l'emploi ne veux pas
parler de ça ça m'intéresse pas faut
être sérieux il faut être sérieux
c'est à dire qu'on ne peut pas se
contenter aujourd'hui d'un syndicaliste
uniquement de la fiche de paye est la
défense des intérêts particuliers vous
devons aussi avoir une vision de
l'intérêt général est aujourd'hui delà
des régionales c'est le fonctionnement
de l'économie à jeudi rayon un peu
d'ambition et lyon nous aussi les
organisations syndicales un petit peu
d'ambition j'ai entendu dans le discours
du premier ministre qui était pas un
discours fantastique il faut bien
reconnaître que c'est à dire que on
s'attendait rien de particulier à son
discours
si ce n'est qu'il a répétée les
promesses et que dire on y va bon ça
c'est le je dirais c'est non mais c'est
celle exercice de style qui est pour
tout premier ministre il a dit une chose
je crois au contrat c'est à dire que je
crois à la négociation au nom de je
crois au contrat donnant donnant c'est
quelque chose qui qui personnellement
mais en même temps c'est une mise en
responsabilité des partenaires sociaux
qu'est ce qui nous dit et où dit vous
les syndicats qui veulent toujours
négocier il faut que vous fassiez vos
preuves
donc je pense que à la sortie du sommet
social est ce qu'on est capable de faire
nos preuves au printemps de nom mais en
même temps il a expliqué que le
redressement prendra du temps à 11,10
pas tellement leur renégociation et
revendications franchement y'a pas grand
chose a donné d'un côté attendait entre
eux croyez que vous croyez que les
salariés dans les entreprises
aujourd'hui il se contente de négocier
que quand il ya quelque chose je dirais
à améliorer dans le pouvoir d'achat qui
font nos équipes syndicales qui
attendait vers france leur situation
situ sont bien obligés de regarder la
réalité économique de leur entreprise
pour faire en sorte
malheureusement qui limite la casse nous
pouvons pas nous les leaders syndicaux
ont disons nous on s'occupe du pouvoir
d'achat et ont laissé nos équipes
syndicales sur le terrain se débrouiller
avec les problèmes donc il faut aussi
que nous on trouve des outils pour
qu'ils sont celui qui qu'ils aient des
outils plus efficaces pour régler leur
situation
je ne peux pas d'un côté moi dire je
veux pas parler du marché du travail
et puis de voir dans quel état la
section syndicale ou le syndicat cfdt
d'air france est en train de négocier
pour sauver des emplois air france c'est
le réalisme à la mode p2p
écoutez c'est la cfdt a social vous
sensible et tout d'ailleurs à ce propos
vous voudriez la constitutionnaliser
comme le souhaite le gouvernement
et c'est un élément important c'est à
dire que dans une société a pesé apaisé
c'est une société où la loi ne fait pas
tout c'est à dire ou dans la société
il y a des syndicats il ya des
associations
il ya des représentants du patronat qui
sont capables aussi de participer à la
construction du changement si ce n'est
ce pas simplement vous savez on est dans
une espèce de de jeu qui est désagréable
c'est que nous on dit négociations le
gouvernement de temps en temps il dit
oui puis là on est bien embêté parce
qu'il faut amener des résultats
et puis quand le dre une gouvernement
décide on dire c'est pas normal il
décide tout seul quand on est bien
content des fois qu'il décide tout seul
là la constitutionalisation si
simplement c'est simple écrit dans la
constitution qu'une loi dans le domaine
du social ne serait plus constitutionnel
si elle n'a pas été soumise à la
négociation préalable
donc ça empêche les députés de passer en
force mais ça oblige aussi les
partenaires sociaux de prendre la
responsable d'une promesse de françois
hollande on le rappelle me citer un et
des attentatoire à la liberté syndicale
c'est extraordinaire c'est à tort la
liberté de négociation alors elle se
comprend pas
j'avais oublié mois mais j'allais vous
posez la question dans les spéciales ne
comprend pas au contraire pas de wc
c'est c'est de redonner du pouvoir aux
organisations syndicales qui met la
france est en retard je dirais d'un
siècle par un par exemple vous parliez
la compétitivité vous avec un des
éléments forts de la compétitivité en
allemagne c'est dialogue social c'est la
place que prennent les organisations
syndicales dans la gestion des
entreprises
donc au bout d'un moment c'est un
élément qui est fort aussi dans la
modernisation
c'est simplement le modèle européen
c'était s'était inscrit dans les textes
européens
c'est à dire le dialogue social est un
élément constitutif de l'organisation de
la démocratie c'est quand même important
très bien prenons dernière question eu
d'annulation peut-être il ya 1,3 million
chômeurs avoir à peu près qu
actuellement est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que les premières mesures
qui sont annoncées
je pense aux 80 mille contrats aidés
supplémentaires qu'a annoncé michel
sapin ya pas très longtemps les cent
cinquante mille emplois d'avenir
les contrats de génération y compris
d'ailleurs un peu l'euro du service
civique est ce que vous pensez donc
ça peu dégonflé ces chiffres quand même
un peu effrayant je vous ai parlé de 150
jeunes qui sortent du système scolaire
sans qualification tous les ans on est
obligé de leur donner une deuxième
chance
on ne peut pas les laisser dans cette
situation là si ce n'est des rustines
ont finalisé les eurent cédé mesures qui
sont nécessaires parce que ça nous
permet d'accompagner ces jeunes et
faisons en sorte que ces contrats aidés
leur permettent de leur donner une
première expérience puis ensuite
peut-être une qualification
je veux dire c'est pas simplement pour
les occuper il faut que ça soit un
élément je dirais dans leur nouveau
parcours mais en même temps vous avez
raison ça suffit pas si derrière on n'a
pas le débat sur la politique
industrielle sur la recherche le
développement qui sont la table ronde à
laquelle je participerai parce que je
pense que mon rôle c'est d'aller dans
dans la table ronde qui va être le plus
important dans l'avenir c'est pour ça
que j'y serai personnellement si on fait
pas ce travail là malheureusement on
pourra faire des contrats aidés pendant
10 ans on trouvera pas le la voie de la
croissance donc vous avez raison il faut
faire les deux très bien merci bruno la
cfdt donc défendra ses propositions lors
de cette conférence sociale s plus dur
pour vous d'avoir en face un
gouvernement de gauche c'est la question
que nous nous sommes posée et à laquelle
tente de répondre avant les questions de
perrine tarneaud qui nous rejoint jérôme
rabier une cgt ont mué dans une guerre
de succession un patronat jugé trop
proche de la droite
à une semaine du sommet social c'est
bien la cfdt qui apparaît comme le
principal interlocuteur de l'exécutif
avec sa ligne réformiste de gauche
assumer la centrale de belleville veut
profiter de la situation pour renforcer
ses positions et ils sont clairement en
ordre de bataille pour préparer la
rentrée sociale pour préparer les défis
de demain en matière sociale la
difficulté principale pour la série tck
devait être bien seul aujourd'hui pour
négocier face au pouvoir politique qui
en plus a tous les pouvoirs
donc ça va être très compliqué pour elle
très vite matignon a reçu les syndicats
françois chérèque en tête
il va maintenant falloir trouver la
bonne distance et quitter les habits
d'opposant sans pour autant devenir un
allié aveugle du nouveau pouvoir
socialiste
après cinq ans de présidence sarkozy ou
les centrales se plaignait du manque de
dialogue social
les attentes sont grandes mais pourrait
générer de la frustration
démon de gauche par principe ça c'est
mieux que des syndicalistes ce qu'il
faut faire en matière sociale donc ils
se reportent assez peu sur eux et ils se
coordonnent assez peu avec les centrales
syndicales et on l'a vu avec les 35
heures ou c'était parti de bons
sentiments à la base et après ça est
devenu très très compliqué puisque tout
a été fait de manière assez dictatorial
ou assez autoritaire l'urgence
économique impose également un nouveau
positionnement syndicales la cfdt
d'ailleurs la seule centrale à ne pas
s'être ému du faible coup de pouce au
smic
une façon de rappeler sa sobriété la
cfdt comme les autres organisations
savent qu'aujourd'hui ça y est c'est
tout de suite 1983 84 1 qui arrive c'est
à dire la rigueur le correct et le
collectif budgétaire
il va falloir faire des économies et
donc la cfdt se situe déjà dans une
position non pas de compréhension mais
d'interlocuteurs aujourd'hui inquiet
peut-être demain plus exigeants le
sommet social des 9 et 10 juillet
indiquera le rôle qu'auront les
partenaires sociaux pour le prochain
quinquennat
la cfdt de lasbordes en position de
force tout en sachant qu'il sera
difficile de dégager des marges de
manoeuvre financières pour satisfaire
les salariés
erin la cgt en crise interne à ce que
c'est un avantage pour la cfdt pour moi
honnêtement c'est pas une préoccupation
pour pour là c'est le btcc préoccupation
pour la c pour la cgt nous nous faisons
notre travail
d'ailleurs marc landry le dit nous
sommes préparés qui est une alternance
pas une alternance donc nous sommes
prêts donc là l'important c'est
d'avancer
ça vous met quand même en première ligne
face au gouvernement vous savez j'ai
quand même l'habitude depuis le temps de
ne pas voir une cgt qui soit vraiment
par le partenaire le plus efficace dans
les négociations puisqu'il signe pas
donc le ballon ça change pas grand chose
justement est-ce que affaibli par ses
divisions la cgt peut encore peser dans
les futures négociations faut le
demander à la saisie d y répondre on lui
et ben vous regardez le nombre de
négociations ces dix dernières années et
le nombre de fois cassé et et s'est
engagée vous aurez la réponse donc ça je
ne suis pas sûr que ça choque beaucoup
mais ceci dit on a peut-être une bonne
surprise
c'est quoi la bonne distance à tenir
pour la cfdt vis-à-vis face à un
gouvernement de gauche
vous avez raison que c'est plus
compliqué qu'avec un gouvernement de
droite parfois pourquoi pourquoi pas
simplement parce que on sait très bien
et rendre la vue dans les sondages
sortie des urnes
les sympathisants de la cfdt au sens
large ont voté dès le premier tour d'une
façon majoritaire pour françois hollande
enfin là je vous ai donc là mais non non
non non justement non non non parce que
je pense que exigeant willm exigences ça
veut dire qu'on fait de travail de
syndicaliste les deux finalistes
on est réaliste on sait très bien
d'expérience que non non non c'est pas
oublié comment ça on sait très bien
d'expérience sur le l'a vu le
gouvernement jospin
l'exemple de marc landré sur les 35
heures ce n'était pas obligatoire notre
méthode le conflit qu'on a eue avec
martine aubry sur le plan des de retour
à l'emploi cpne c'était aussi tôt qu'au
c'est très très bien que parfois un
gouvernement de gauche comme il l'a dit
a tendance à tout savoir à notre place
ou tendance à dire la cfdt puisqu'elle
elle est plutôt pour leurs adhérents
derrière nous on n'a pas besoin d'eux
mais je crois que c'est de cette
expérience qu'ont qu'on retire le fait
que nous sommes exigeants sur les
mesures qui devra prendre et vous avez
dans vos premières discussions avec
françois hollande et jean marc ayrault
vous avez déjà posé les jalons de cette
exigence vous leur avez dit que vous ne
seriez pas un ami aveugle nous déjà on
leur a parlé beaucoup de méthodes un
tout le monde note que la méthode est
utilisée tout nouvel que ces deux
méthodes de construction je dirais d'un
dialogue mais c'est pas mal inspiré de
ce que propose à cm dit voilà donc
hasard vers deux adresses une écoute à
partir du moment où on reprend nos idées
j'ai quand même pas plaindre après dit
bien ça sera dans l'exigence et je crois
que j'aille voir balisé depuis le début
de l'émission des éléments forme
d'exigences qui sont peut-être pas les
mêmes que les autres mais qui au niveau
du résultat pour les salariés peuvent
peser loi vous n'avez pas à vous
plaindre vous venez de le dire est ce
que vous iriez jusqu'à dire que votre
signe et entendue voire même privilégié
par rapport aux autres syndicats non je
crois que c'est un nom mais que je suis
arrivé moi secrétaire général j'ai été
le secrétaire général qui a fait une
réforme des retraites avec un
gouvernement de droite et on a parlé
pendant cinq ans dallier privilégie le
gouvernement de droite
maintenant il ya un gouvernement de
gauche qui arrive et on dit assez petit
et partenaires privés
lang gauche pourquoi simplement parce
que comme unité dit dans le reportage
nous travaillons nous faisons des
propositions
nous sommes arrivés arrivé avec 50 pages
de propositions avec le gouvernement je
pense que tout le monde peut le faire en
tout cas nous on l'a fait et le réalise
comme la vie du tout à l'heure elle
faut-il comme le demande
l'association nationale des drh des
ressources humaines transformé trois
jours fériés chrétiens en jour libre de
fermeture par l'incendié parce qu'on a
autre chose à penser
franchement est-ce que ça arrive des
erreurs non mais attendez ce sont les
des restes des grandes boîtes ce sont
les drh des entreprises qui sont en
train de faire des plans sociaux
il peut se passe au cul paix des
éléments essentiels aujourd'hui vous
croyez pas que ce n'est pas le débat
aujourd'hui
franchement moi je je pense que si l'uci
géant pouvoir toujours les avoir au
niveau intellectuel mais ça change quoi
ça changera pratiquement rien passé ça
va changer les noms pas obligatoire
puisque les gens ils auront trois jours
de congé si jeune que ça veut dire
qu'ils vont dire que fred moi je suis
chrétien moi je suis musulman mais moi
je suis comme ça je serai parfois
déranger je dis aujourd'hui la priorité
c'est pas celle là
la priorité c'est de s'occuper des
problèmes des plans sociaux dans les
entreprises
s'occuper des problèmes de pouvoir
d'achat pour les salariés en partie
destruction smic c'est ça notre priorité
aujourd'hui après qu'on aura avancé sur
ce sujet là on pourra toujours parler de
ça quels sont les jeux je vois pas où
savoir si c'est si c'est pour supprimer
trois jours pour les salariés ça la
réponse vous l'avez évidemment
évidemment à venir il faut pas nous
prendre pour des andouilles non plus
franchement même vous vous le savez vous
de votre barre je veux bien que c'est ça
on essaie de ne pas être pris pour des
andouilles ce moment là que même
quotidien c'est vrai qu'on a un
partenariat dans cette émission avec
orange et leur application
tvcheck alors il ya quelques questions
qui nous arrive notamment celle de
françois bonnel vous allez quitter quand
la cfdt
un jour je vais vous faire une
confidence j'ai jamais été aussi proche
du moment je vais partir est ce que vous
allez profiter par exemple de
l'assemblée générale
la mi novembre l'assemblée ne s'est pas
là aujourd'hui c'est pas le débat
aujourd'hui j'ai la conférence sociale
j'ai tout cet été pour y penser on verra
après l'été c'est un calendrier qui
était en même temps vient de nous en
parler plus aujourd'hui seniors on en
parlait pourtant ouvertement on en a
même parlé ensemble ici même et j'avais
parlé ils ont parlé faisait parler
non non non j'ai parlé ici avec vous
qu'un jour que je partirai d'activité je
suis dans mon dernier mandat
ça c'est une certitude et d'ailleurs
c'est une cercle c'est une certitude
aussi ce qui se rapporte au débat public
c'est à dire que je pense qu'au bout
d'un moment il faut savoir passer la
main mais ce que vous avez été refroidis
par les désaccords internes à la cgt
non parce que ceux des balades de ma
succession ça fait maintenant deux ans
que nous l'avons le bureau national y
apprendre un peu moins d'une année à
désigner un secrétaire général adjoint
laurent berger et l'a désigné en
connaissance de cause en sachant que le
jour où ça sera lui donc vous verrez
bien je le jour est ce que bernard
thibault vous montre aujourd'hui comment
rater sa sortie
non je suis pas jay pas juger ce qui se
passe à la cgt honnêtement en tout cas
moi ce que j'explique c'est ce que je
fais c'est que je suis à l'écouté des
militants de l'assé petit et j'ai écouté
ce qu'ils le disent depuis un moment a
lieu au dernier congrès j'ai annoncé que
c'était mon dernier mandat
tout le monde sait que dans le bureau
national on débattait au tour est-ce que
ses doigts que l'embellie militants
s'expriment quand ils me rencontrent
cogne parle donc je sais à peu près
j'écoute respirer la sérénité à partir
de ce moment là je pense que ça se passe
mieux
on vous dit intéressé par la présidence
de m france non mais ça je crois que
c'est d'ailleurs marc landré je lui dise
que le 32e congrès du figaro qui a fait
une indélicatesse
non je ne crois que ce qui d'ailleurs
est ma lysiane non mais de la lutte
contre l'armée mais vous rendez compte
vous rendez compte
non mais de mémoire c'est une
humiliation comme ça ça veut dire que je
parlerai de la lutte contre la pauvreté
pour des intérêts particuliers
les miens emmaüs vient de désigner un
président il ya un mois un mois donc
respectons respectons ces gens là et si
je pars de la lutte contre la pauvreté
c'est que je la rencontre la pauvreté
j'en rencontre je pense je regarde
j'écoute 30% des femmes 32 soulevé
sensible 30% des femmes en france
avec - du smic annuel mais c'est ça le
problème
c'est pour ça que je veux parler de la
lutte contre la pauvreté c'est pas parce
que j'ai des ambitions personnelles dans
telle ou telle association ça serait
ridicule c'est vrai que c'est un combat
sur lequel les syndicats n'ont guère de
prise aujourd'hui si vous suivez oui
mais c'est une histoire qui et je dirai
oublier à notre création
c'est une histoire qui est directement
liée à nos valeurs c'est à dire que ce
sujet de la dette
je les pose et il ya huit ans au congrès
de la cfdt parce que on sait très bien
qu'un pays qui s'endettent oublie les
plus pauvres c'est ça la réalité
donc je pense que c'est pas une surprise
que la cfdt met ça dans le débat public
enfin en même temps vous connaissez le
poids de la redistribution sociale dans
notre pays on peut pas dire que notre
pays très endetté depuis des années
négligent de plus pauvres objectivement
j'ai pas dit ça
non mais jeudi malgré ça la pauvreté
elle s'accroît et je crois plus chez les
retraités et s'accroît chez les jeunes
donc vous avez remarqué aussi que depuis
cette émission je pose pourquoi parce
que je vois bien que dans le débat
public
les jeunes ont voté plus aussi pour le
front national que les moins jeunes ils
ont plus confiance au système de
protection sociale il n'arrive pas à
avoir un parcours officiel normal pour
retrouver au travail ils sont dans la
pauvreté
donc ils partent après via des mauvaises
hull qui leur font croire qu'ils
pourront changer le monde en quittant
l'europe et compagnie mais il faut
derrière qu'on leur amène des réponses
donc mon rôle de syndicaliste aussi
c'est à dire ce sont des salariés dont
il faut parler c'est des combats de
sociétés dont doivent dont doivent
s'accaparer les syndicats pour notamment
ça peut être une façon de lutter contre
l'hémorragie persistant de leurs troupes
en france c'est d'abord une question de
morale avant je me risque d'altérer à
cannes mais parce qu'on fait ce travail
là que les associations nous avons
d'aider des réseaux de travail ce qu'on
appelle résout alerte ou les
organisations syndicales le medef
travail et les associations
donc le premier ministre a confirmé cet
après midi qu'il allait faire je dirais
un travail avec le monde associatif non
chouette que les syndicats y travaillent
parce qu'on ne peut pas vendre
peu importe que je pense que c'est
l'important que ses filles efficace je
dirais importe c'est un peu importe la
forme on peut pas continuer à dire les
syndicats le travail et les associations
leur travail ce sont les mêmes salariés
des fois donc on est bien
dir est condamné mais on est obligé par
principe de travailler ensemble vous
sent quand même un porté par ce sujet l
envie peut-être de continuer votre
combat syndical écoutez je suis
travailleur social
d'abord c'est ma profession aussi je
dirais une culture personnelle mais je
ne suis pas encore au clair à ce que je
vais faire la main peut-être dans le
milieu professionnel
non honnêtement je n'ai encore pas je
réfléchirai vous savez je sais qu'un
jour et fruits c'est une date je pense
que je mets ma paroisse ya des
opportunités qui se présentent
elle avait peur on verra bien on verra
bien et vous comptez prendre votre
décision est elle annoncée quant à
l'automne prochain
vous croyez que c'est un débat qui
intéresse les vos auditeurs vos
téléspectateurs s'en foutent de la
viande se rattache à la cfdt
ce qui les intéresse c'est clair que
c'est le fruit l'essonne oui bah je suis
sensible mais vous verrez toujours
partir je partirai ils vous diront bien
vite donc l'importance c'est l'ours
aussi et comment on y répond bon déjà
envie de continuer vos responsabilités
syndicales avec un gouvernement de
gauche on sait il le faire passer le
message aussi que je me sens bien parce
que je crois que la cfdt et vous crois
que vous comprenez a envie de changer
les choses a envie de répondre à ces
difficultés les petites entreprises y
aura par exemple en fin d'année une
élection dans les petites entreprises
les petites entreprises c'est ceux des
salariés qui sont au smic
c'est pour ça que nous avons dit au
gouvernement les heures supplémentaires
attention ils ont nos besoins ce sont là
aussi ces entreprises là qui accueille
les jeunes donc je pense qu'on a envie
de changer les choses parce que je crois
que la cgt est un syndicat qui ne se
préoccupe pas uniquement que de petits
problèmes mais c'est que de voir aussi
d'accéder au sein de tous dehors demain
le combat continuera donc pour vous
france haché avec merci au revoir
d'avoir été avec nous aujourd'hui la
semaine prochaine père et nous recevrons
le ministre de l'agriculture monsieur
stéphane le foll proche du président de
la république pour lequel d'ailleurs le
premier ministre a annoncé une loi cadre
on en parlera bonsoir a très vite